ceo this is kenny calling from portland
hey kenny thank you for calling in
portland they say they got a lot of
beautiful strippers up there
and a lot of rain
so if you like that whap that's your
territory baby
you know if you like a damp girl that's
really pale skin but tatted up
if you like one of them antifa bad
beaches
that's your territory onward uh
i had an idea here i have a playstation
5 that i got from my work
uh i'm not really a big gamer but i
would like to offer that to one of your
struggling single
moms so if you have any ladies out there
that are trying to make your kid happy
on the holiday
i have a playstation 5 that i'll be
willing to
donate uh only because your show gives
me
hours of entertainment throughout the
week uh you're very positive
i love the things that you have to say
and uh game game
gang gang man thank you kenny that's man
that's where it's at
you know that's where it's at um and we
we we would love that
if you if you know a single mom that
could use this gift uh you can hit the
hotline 985-664-9503
um you know and and
and think just think about if you don't
don't call don't don't give us some lady
that can't use it
don't give us some lady that's going to
sell it and buy the larded out there
or buy a couple grams of this or a ro or
a rock a crack
you know if you have somebody you think
can you can use it has some children
there and
don't if the children already dumb they
might not need a ps5
get them bastards of ps3
but if you got a woman that's got a
couple of kids
that's very kind of you kenny we'll
reach out man and uh
we'll see what we can do we'll take a
couple of suggestions if you can hit the
hotline 985-664-9503
um that'd be awesome you know uh
it's that time of year man it's that
time of year to to extend a little if
you can
um you know the other day i was
was i was eating breakfast here out here
in the central east which is where i'm
at and
uh and i ended up paying for
um the breakfast there was a couple
sitting outside
and when i walked in the guy said i said
hey and him and his girlfriend were just
visiting in town and so before i left i
just bought my meal bought their meal
um and just left you know
and then and i'm just saying that
because about
two weeks later i'm across the street
eating breakfast
at a different place uh with josh wolfe
and we get up to pay and leave and they
said oh somebody
bought your meal i said dang
didn't know who i don't know who it was
you know some damn scrooge mcduck
got warm-hearted you know got that mayor
is just fired
you know he grilled his own a orders
with the lord
with that lord's traeger or something
something hit him he got heated in the
heart and somebody bought me that damn
meal
so that's what you know it's just it's
just that's caramel roulette and that
karma will really this
this the time of year when karma is out
there
karma got on the zoot suit karma's
listening to 21 savages
karma's out there baby karma got his
nose hairs clipped out he's out there
he's got a fresh set of tits on karma's
living hard right now
this when karma is paying attention
so it's a great time to extend that
olive leaf to somebody
how can i help what can i do
and when i get up in the morning this
week what's been making me feel good
is just saying what can i do
what can i do for somebody that's not me
who can i call that would like to hear
my voice today
and not in like an ego way but just who
can i call that i know could use
uh somebody just they they're looking
for anybody in the world to call them
and say hey
how are you where is your head at
where's your heart at
and sometimes that can be you that can
be anybody
but i have to remember when i get up to
ask myself that question first
so um
so anyway what a small little world how
that worked out
uh but thank you kenny we'll find
somewhere we'll find someone who can use
it i think
so hit the hotline if you have some
suggestions i'm just sitting on your
front porch wondering how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been